okay so i restarted the broadcast i got
an error message when i first started it
so i'm hoping it it is on give me a
quick info if I'm really online a quick
message would be great I can also check
myself here yeah I think I think we're
good but it's always good to have a
quick confirmation in the chat yeah okay
thanks guys for the information yeah I
had an error message at first but it
seems to be good now yeah let's get
going yeah I'm going to play a couple of
five minutes games I have to really play
better than last week yeah it was kind
of I didn't do a good job last week so
let's get some games going have a pretty
decent rating again above 2400 so won't
be easy a GF okay some guy here playing
b6 on me it's not really great to be
perfectly honest this this line let's
see I think this is a very risky way to
play ok this is this as well risky is
putting it mildly let's set see what
happens here night F for coming and I'm
ready to get the Queen into the game
Queen to h5 or queen g-form yeah Queen
gvoice is in fact quite good already
let's see how is defending ok I have
night h5 already g6 bishop age 6 let's
let's just play the the normal looking
moves and see what happens Bishop here
and just just be aggressive ok he's
giving up the exchange ok I'm going to
take it and ask questions later ok how
do we how do we proceed I think I want
to make sure that my bishop get
something to go when did you get that
rating yeah but I mean if you watch my
channel this always some delay I mean
yeah the videos that are uploaded daily
it doesn't really currently I'm
recording stuff that is going to be
released in March so there's always this
delaying thing um okay what am I going
to do here yeah my night or h5 is active
but it's also a bit shaky there so let's
try to get it into play night f5 maybe
would be nice I'm an exchange up that's
good but still have to have to win the
game night before or Bishop Bishop b4 be
sure before looks good actually yeah
he's kind of it's a bit of a shaky
position if we look at this Bishop takes
Knight takes these seven hangs and f6
hangs kind of Oh
game let's go here now looks very shaky
yeah hello guys get hope there are some
new new people around isn't this just
winning lie morooka up here right now I
have a piece of i'm sorry i wasn't
exchange up now i'm a piece of
hmm it was nice their only hope that he
has us this strong partner on d4 so I
should be a bit cautious there that the
part is not getting dangerous first
secure my McQueen side and then see what
to do um h4 h5 looks looks good right
yeah making some lift for working yeah
here we go he really has little actor
that he can do if he goes d3 the part
actually gets weak some yellow to
Fibonacci 85 yeah you watch my three
games every morning thanks for that yeah
I actually do know people who told me
that this that this is a regular morning
routine to watch my hip my blitz games
it's funny thanks for that I actually
also watched YouTube in the morning for
breakfast but normally not chess I tend
to watch some non chest stuff for a
change
okay I'm trying to activate my night iam
yeah thanks for the positive feedback on
my new series with the viewer games i'm
reviewing the viewer games and it's um
it's a new regular feature of the
channel and i have a large backlog yeah
like 30 30 games maybe the I've really
got a ton of ton of those okay I'm
taking this opportunity here 92 to get
it to e4 at a moment where a 2 is not
hanging
so 94 on John looks right here yeah I
gave okay got very positive feedback
from the from the viewer who sent in the
game yes he is giving me another look
that's nice yep I've got the first one
in okay so better start then then last
week I think winning winning a game yeah
yeah as mentioned also watch YouTube
stuff in the morning but I usually watch
car stuff here car reviews or stuff like
that I like Jay Leno's Garage if you I
into into cos then it's it's nice to
watch jay leno is looking at the old
cars or whatever it's really funny ok we
have a Queens gambit declined against
con tourists from Ireland it's their
name let's check no I secure a
five-minute player only has five minute
games and that's funny usually people do
do devil and something else I didn't see
today's game mvl against Tomashevsky i
think tomorrow Tomashevsky one this he's
doing very good he's doing very good in
this in this tournament okay so what do
we have here it's a Bishop f4 and
okay um what do I do here we should be
five is a move Queen f3 is also not bad
I'm going for queen of three this kind
of setup there's a question by Carol car
99 about the line in the Kings Indian
with c6 and d5 um yeah let's play oh ok
in this game now I'm threatening 97 so
funny threat which she which he noticed
but I will get the chance in to play F
for now going for a direct attack you
with f5 and trying to check meet him it
is not easy to defend I hope it looks
difficult for me to defend
came someone to take um yeah I'm a
taking d7 buddy and I'm going to take
this I'm very materialistic in that way
instead of some trick I don't think so
this is one point of Queen h3 and that
you cannot move the the night down he's
just very generously giving me this
night unless I'm overlooking something I
really hope I'm not and I also got a
question about the the Chi Goren Chi
Goren ruin apes' the carrier slide with
1197 cannot quote all the moves yeah I
think that's interesting the line it's a
very sharp line with eat XD actually
played it once against Daniel Stellwagen
strong GM nowadays and he's almost
retired in a very young age but very
strong GM and I lost from a very nice
very nice position ok next game matter
i'm getting a good series in here to win
so I mini mini series or streak streak
of wins
there was a question about the sea 65
Kings Indian type of line yeah that's it
so that's an interesting that's an
interesting line can can be played I
looked at this once but yeah I actually
get a new game I wanted to put it on the
board actually to show you what I saw me
about in Nick part 2 333 I'm the rating
actually that is the rating right that
is the rating let's see I'm going to
play the Grand Prix attack reversed
which is actually better than the
original Grand Prix attack it's not that
bad how Knight f3 okay yeah sending a PG
end file would be nice for the viewer
for the viewer games you can also just
put the moves into a male but it should
be something that I can paste into into
chessbase with PGN okay III okay this
guy is some prolly really knowing what
is doing which is not good news never is
right they actually know something about
the game ah then it gets critical yeah
okay from funny jokes aside playing
chess after seven is always an
interesting experience so not relying on
their own theory yeah it looks like he
wanted to go night edge flow I just
wondered yeah he took took a while to do
that
oh yeah I'm wondering can I go if I take
in 95 is this a more voices nonsense I
mean taking on f5 looks a bit risky
maybe he can do it but I'm gambling here
yeah night f5 I just castling I'm just
castling 493 and canceling its hmm maybe
that's really nonsense right now that I
think of it it might be a bit too much
but he believed me he believed my gamble
so I can castle now right keeping f5
covered and threatening g5 winning a
piece but it's kind of a shaky piece and
there's a mention of a Nigel Davies book
ii 45 for black it is quite ok this book
I have it it's um it's a bit outdated
but not hopelessly it's a couple of
years old yeah I mean nowadays what I
would would go for is actually for um
for the sidelines the Beauregard book
the bolo gun black weapons and for the
wait there's no clear book really that
can be recommended yaanai g6 hmm I don't
want that but 94 he might take on f5
right maybe still what I need to do
9f 5d6 is my idea probably this is total
in total nonsense it might be okay it's
a plane gambits a good idea for
beginning players or should I go for a
more solid approach um playing gambits
it's not a bad idea it teaches you peace
play and dynamics well but there are not
so many good gambits around you should
be quite selective not play any kind of
pawn sacrifice that that comes to mind
there should be there should be some
quality of throwing for example let's
say the Evans gambit yeah it's a really
good gambit yeah them I don't know the
what can the Latvian gambit is rubbish
for example um so you should put in some
effort in selecting your your gambit
lines um okay um that's not good I mean
he played it he played it well h3 as a
cool move Bishop f5 hd6 it looks like
I'm losing one of those pawns but okay
if he takes on d3 after hg i will take
the Jeep on and that's not so clear
that's not so clear the King's gambit
actually would not recommend to a
beginning player it's not a gambit in
them in them in the typical sense
because in the Kings can but you don't
get in development advantage them
gambits that give you a development
advantage are really quite okay there's
a question if I can name a couple of D
for openings that require minimum study
not so sure actually
yeah the Queens gambit um of course is
not a real gambit okie dokie is
attacking here after Queen d3 will
attack on age seven that's not good news
hmm how do I play here Queenie seven
maybe just here in d3 h6 and go from go
from there I have ideas with just
pressurizing the e porn yeah you can
play deform in a somewhat in a simple
fashion yeah with the london system and
green pond stuff but this is kind of pet
servants it's not bad but it's not
really great to learn chess let's say
especially dynamic chess rather go for
main lines I really recommend my
students to to play em Queen porn
openings I mean Queen porn like the
London system and stuff they can play d4
of course but not I don't like the the
non theoretical stuff that much because
it's very often passive okay so i will
take g4 but he's got Queen g6 some
moment have to but I've got Bishop f5
right so I can take I can take this
yeah I cannot take you three
unfortunately I wonder if there's some
way bishop age three sucking the
exchange not really him Wow hmm rook age
6 hmm oh wow I totally forgot about this
this thread ah yeah that's bad totally
forgot about that oh wow okay mmm he's
not taking but but he will right now no
I have no way to prevent it that's the
worst part you can very conveniently
take them Wow
yeah trying for count to play against
the pawn okay so what is this is this
let's play try to play actively takes
for rookie three getting in there yeah
winning this spawn at least and now
trying to get the d5 pawn over the king
of King is very active ask a droopy 70 t
king is six
what a mesum now you can go to be five
there any way to maybe here just about
hanging on here but yeah I am ok let's
try ok ah I gotta draw I gotta draw who
you you you that was a mud was too bad
ah enigma tells me good game not sure I
was a good fight it was a good fight
let's get the next one in I really
couldn't couldn't look at him and then
the comments ah let's see
yeah if you build up a d4 repertoire um
you should find a good balance between
not term not spending am not spending
too much time on theory but not playing
it too without any ambition yeah a good
d for repertoires also involving time
it's not it's not that it is much easier
to do than doing it with the FOIA d4 is
not less theory then they need for a few
if you want it like that and I don't get
a game here what's going on yep yeah you
can also play d 4 2nite f3 and then C
for that avoids some lines there's no
big drawback in that there's a question
have any of your opponent's spent like
half an hour on move three or four no
didn't happen I know that some years ago
um a friend of mine nowadays a
grandmaster and he played in the Belgium
league and I also play the burgundy but
it was one of those some matches where I
wasn't playing so I was am at home doing
something else and he played and he had
the honor to play David Bronstein the
World Championship challenger who played
a mahabharat Winnick in 1954 and
Bronstein was famous for spending lots
of time in the first couple of moves and
against my friend he spent I think 20
minutes on move one my friend played
Knight f3 and Bronstein took 20 minutes
to play 1d6 it's crazy right it ended in
a draw i think if i remember correctly
ok so i didn't really think about that
move too much I probably should have
because how do I protect this there's
also 95 coming hmm
hmm that's bad news Queen f6 s95 oh what
a disaster Wow
and hey don't see you move I don't see a
move that I can play him
this is total total disaster green age
five amazing ok now after night x I can
play Bishop b6 and I hope I'm surviving
for a little bit after Bishop takes I
play Queen c7 and hope for the best if i
play qui vive play Queen c70 merely does
95 and maybe I could have done that
actually for Queen d8 back there's a
question what endgame books do i
recommend that's easy actually I
recommend two books on if you want
something to start from let's say a
basic book that has everything that you
essentially need to know this is a thing
that i recommend the book by pesos drvr
Garcia 100 and games you must know he is
just putting out 100 end games that he
considers essential and indian studies
them this is really excellent it's the
the basic stuff you need and if you are
better if you're a better player like
two thousand and above really clearly
above that you can get to orange to red
skis and gay men you were with a modern
classic of endgames those two books are
actually almost enough for theoretical
and games from practical end games they
are less there's some more but it's all
on them all on a level that term this is
pretty pretty high so for most players
from the day of yearbook and Tourette's
keys book is fantastic you don't need
much more or anything more okay in this
game I'm just getting destroyed there's
simply there's no nice way to put it
this guy's completely annihilating me 95
m
but we have nothing I can do about it it
just totally totally lost position what
a mess the only hope that I have and
this is very little very slight hobus
and he is playing really slowly a 95 is
still coming now what I miss Bishop d7
he can still play 95 and I'm and I'm
gone could have done that before
actually if I castle short he's got f6
and I'm also losing maybe I should move
the Queen iya wow this is really one of
the worst positions that have that I
have him they've had for a while what is
he doing now let's see I mean 95 for f6
looks crushing but he kind of he ii am
didn't play in the most okay 95 I can
take on f5 maybe that's a little tactic
ok that's it sits we're still as before
I'm still take he's taking lots of time
he can just play 92 or any move and is
better but he's spending time maybe
trying to really really kill me
yeah hi meat grinder yep show is on for
30 minutes now and got a funny game here
where where I'm playing as slowly slowly
as usual but this guy is trying to make
a competition out of it also thinking
for a long time that isn't that isn't
exactly a bad move yet he what am i
doing now here that's really really bad
rook g8 there is f6 and I'm lost um
bishop moves yeah I have to write queen
f6 route g8 I had might it might get
funny because he is spending that much
time so Bishop is seven here for f6
water what a mess if i take f5 here
Knight f6 check hmm I mean I mean some
discovered checks it it really is not
mattering this is so lost Queen g7 are
you can play amazing
do you play the leningrad or stone
bosses question to me I played both a
little bit but not not at the moment in
in in serious chess wow what a crap
position 97 amazing now come on where's
the button but what a beating what a
beating oh this guy's no I'm not wanting
I don't want to look at it again yeah if
I really f5 really was was a bit a bit
much that's just a bad move is a
question I'm 2400 T in the rating how
big I with the retching be without
commentary yeah maybe 50 or 100 points
or something I don't know I was 2500 at
some point but i cannot i cannot
maintain this rating i'm kind of
floating between I rarely go but I
rarely go under 2,300 usually floating
between 23 and 25 my opinion on the
Kings gambit yeah simple should be
avoided it's um it's not really worth it
it's it can be a surprise weapon maybe
but it is some kind of risky and it's
the risk-reward ratio is relatively low
I think yeah I wanted to get a new game
but it's not materializing not so much
action yet at the moment but there are
there are a couple of five minute
that's a funny handler I gotta see a
handle here of a player not megan fox
but vagin fox the vague and Fox the Fox
that's only eating vegetables that's
kind of funny no I never tried the Borg
opening it's not not really great I
think um I wanted to game here bodies ok
here I get one is a gladiator or
something like that he's a gladiator
this is a Hoffman maybe yeah he's a
Hoffman he is often he just released a
book actually on the on e5 yes this guy
has written a book on this opening so
that's interesting he should know
something about it i play my usual line
against this with g3 this is a good way
vegan yeah it's not yeah they called
correcting my pronunciation yeah I
suspected that I'm kind of screwing up
this but ok he interesting he what is he
doing going for b5 it seems like it
that's an interesting setup ok i really
want to stop e5 Knight coming there so
let's let's grab space it's my usual
policy if they give me space I'm going
to take it Wow ok g45 isn't this kind of
a bit much I I see that black is kind of
solid here but it's it's a lot of space
yeah I'm taking
I'm taking taking this opportunity here
okay so if i take him I really want to
get an edge for so night night g 1 2 f 3
would be good that takes a while yeah I
see the point maybe he gets in Bishop g5
hmm interesting okay have to be a bit
quick ahem yeah the sky has written a
book on this opening it has just been
released okay he wants to take him okay
let's start with this move getting one
of his pieces off side okay yeah this is
not totally offside Knight b6 can attack
the pawn on c4 I see the point how
interesting
never should everyone to cover that
however that said that's not a totally
convincing position it's he's not in
such a bad shape and I have to be
cautious yeah if he takes Queen takes
Knight c2 might head ok so let's prepare
bishop f1 and make sure i can use the
look on the second rank ok so he's
taking and what now Queen g5 obvious
interesting threatening f6 now so he has
to play Quincy five already yeah now i
can take play of six again but he has g
six maybe and i have the pieces it's
with their really wrong to exploit this
kind of thing hmm very head player
played this entry and very interesting
way maybe night a 2 at the NTM
hmm its kind of difficult not to trade
queens in this position night a choice
godhra Kade
wow that's not a good position it's just
not good how do I play this we want to
get the look on the a file at least with
night a 2 okay that's just wrong take
stakes rupee to look a phone hmm maybe
it's still what I need to do it's not
very nice I played that thread that well
I have made must have made some some
wrong moves him really really I'm in a
bit of trouble him look ahead is strong
now
yep that's strong okay now i can play
rook a tool right I look beat you i mean
that's helping me a little bit I don't
night a4 I'm just blundering here all
night if I academic a kangaroo p1 sorry
it's just a silly pen it's still a pen I
was thinking I flan during the nighttime
but I'm not okay I mean not that it is
great here this is this position but it
I really thought it was it was even
worse yeah that's not a very fun
position to play you played that very
nicely so what can you do have to have
to trade and now night comes here plus
that's really not good
your gphone is falling but what can you
do it's not taking that okay so let me
keep it yeah it's all nice and good but
it's not really making much progress and
I'm done on time though okay
getting to f3 just giving me g5 not
quite sure why I have c4 protected
there's nothing to to win them
I didn't see King b6 I didn't see this
idea at all
yeah that the worst is over him but it's
still not a position where I can do much
I have to cover see for the time who
he's got huge time edge of course
is offering me a draw that that's very
nice yeah I mean he could win on time
but I think I'm okay now with the Jeep
on he played that very nice layer that's
where that was it was really a tricky
tricky position that was too much sorry
about that yeah that was an interesting
setup that he played I mean here I think
I should be ok I have a huge advantage
in space but starting from here you
really have to question what I did yeah
moves like rook ahead I mean after he
takes with the night here that was
interesting the night is coming to to be
6 and at the text see form yeah night
coming here and this is this is getting
getting tricky sure that's not good yeah
he's getting to a 8 actually thought
that that he could play rook e8 and play
this position that also looks really
nice you can always cover this and then
move the bishop and reroute the night
IAM pretty pretty good for black may I
played that very nicely I think the
experts know what they're doing in their
in their openings ok a new new game
going yeah sorry if I couldn't really I
couldn't really look at them couldn't
really look at them at the chat so yeah
the books are they are via and and Virat
scheme was actually
that mean okay so let's let's see yeah
the droids can also have somewhere but I
have the German version the entropy
universitate in German yeah we're
playing here them we are playing the
entire Marin with Queen c2 and this is
an opening that I don't know yet I want
to study it but i think i have to take
take the other way around actually but
ok we will see what's what happens him
he gets in d4 now right I made a mistake
him ok but I'm in a learning process in
regards to this line um why it's not be
five a movie an ID be five checking on
85 I've got bishops III yeah let's let's
try that maybe I get get the bishop
traded yes I have fun I have played on
on this leech a sly chess it's a it's
okay for free server but well it's just
um well if you play on icc against all
the gm's and so on it's just more fun um
okay Bishop f5 this is not looking good
I didn't see that coming yeah I mean am
opening here that i don't know if i go
Queen d2 is got an ID for that looks
even worse
wow that's really bad I have to take
this what an opening disaster here holy
moly he's got Queen a5 check coming up
wow wow yeah as a question when my when
my book will be released yeah it's an at
the publishers at the moment and they
will they do the the usual things yeah
like proof reading and making sure that
I'm not spelling I'm just blundering
everything here yeah wow what a game him
wow that was embarrassing that was
embarrassing yeah Bishop f5 really hits
him so night be five is nonsense I have
to play Bishop e2 or something yeah we
should be five after that I'm just lost
yeah yeah my book is at the publishers
and yeah kini to I know where there was
no move it was just totally lost anyway
which should be five that was really bad
yeah thnkx balcony bra he says oh my god
you suck I did yeah I did suck in this
game not so much in others but in this
this game it was really really bad okay
let's see what i can do i get low 2 zeta
was just an opening catastrophe it
happens to all players is going for the
London that's not very ambitious let's
see what is doing ok this is this is
ambitious I'm going to try to play
aggressively here with c5 and d5 ok c 5
yeah let's let's get to the central
square cm and try to attack this be take
c5
and it was really a bad game was really
a bad game but yeah lots sometimes hear
you don't know the opening you get into
you get into some trouble especially if
you want to get them get a quick get a
quick move out not to be good at chess
is not only about about openings it's
really not but sometimes if you if you
don't know what's going on and you
really make a stupid move it can lose to
her it can lead to a quick loss as i did
in the game before might be five was
really really stupid stuff let's see a
three if i take on be too what is the
big point is God would be one coming I
can still take but ok I can also just
develop him no problem whatsoever and
night FYI is right and maybe I should
have taken what's the more ambitious way
to play I don't have I don't really have
great square cm ok now I should have
taken me to I really should have I came
so what happens cm knight Knight to c3
would be would be nice night be 695
comes hmm Bishop see 6b five
haha now what a bad player I really I
really should have taken be to really
should have taken them this is not I
mean not in any way near as good as
taking on v2 was now you can take p7
wow really struggling here bad play okay
yeah now i can take a night seaforth
it's not doing much maybe look see a
task a bishop a 6mm that sucks it's
really not nice not a nice position to
have him I have to get rid of the night
you know if he takes I get some activity
and while retreating was no option
anyway young
95 really okay I'm glad I'm glad that he
allowed this let me push the pawn yeah
that's nice yeah that wasn't the best
way for white definitely not I get some
some very welcome activity him that I
really didn't expect to get okay he
might take on deform but still okay
let's let's be active I can I can attack
a three and get rope the aid with temple
you six I ok don't mind that much
yeah listen there's a remark about them
the UM the the game reviews that I do
and I don't don't intend to be to get
shorter and in future videos it depends
very much on the game of course young
mean if the game has enough count
content related to to to cover I mean in
this detail I will cover it it's just as
long as it needs to be yeah this funny
misconception that you can actually make
a good chess video in in 15 minutes when
the content then there's just too much
content to talk about it's also funny
that people think that this is a lower
level game in terms of rating of the
players would take less time to talk
about then a GM level game of course the
opposite is true and it's it's it's
actually very obvious because in the in
them in the amateur game there is simply
larger number of critical points because
they are more turnarounds they simply
simply more stuff happening in the GM
level game there are there are very
little mistakes so the amateur game is
more to talk about no I did not look
through all of the games um I just took
one of the early games that that reach
me and I'm going through them like one
by one what I'll take it I definitely
take the rook yeah you can ask me once
twice three times I'll take it that was
funny you just gave me the rook for
nothing okay we get in get a new game
going and here's the question at the
1500 1600 level is it better to do
tactics or study annotated games yeah
both actually you want to improve your
calculation true but study annotated
games is also very very helpful
to get ideas yeah well annotated game is
helpful to get an idea what are what are
good good ideas good strategies for
certain position types you just learn
how a good chess move looks like yeah if
you if um study annotated games there's
a questions are all God's books too
difficult for 1700 edo rating yeah most
of them are most of them are he's made
some of some very high level books there
they're really great but there are on a
super high level very very high level
okay I'm a final game for the session
playing con tourist again from Ireland
and I declined the l a-- kind invitation
simply because i don't know the opening
okay well let's have some fun here going
to the black madhurima gambit who is
taking like that hmm you see actually
knowing some theory here this is no fun
you play a rubbish opening and they
actually know how to refute it that's
not good okay
hmm that's not fair I am they know how
to play against the black MIDI mayor
what kind of books do top players read
they normally don't read books not a lot
for the openings they do their research
themselves and what they often use for
training is some they use studies and
things like that solving studies and
game studies and cover the calculation
exercises and so on but they usually
find the positions themselves or have
their trainers to find them from find
them but they don't read that many books
it's well known over that Magnus cars
and he actually buys opening books and
looks at them and I really think it's
not a bad idea to catch some idea some
of his openings are definitely inspired
by my books that that are coming out and
why not even you don't have to you don't
have to to play exactly what is in the
books yeah if you look at even some
ideas or sometimes helpful yeah so why
not look at look at stuff okay actually
I'm actually getting some kind of
compensation for the porn not enough
probably but a little bit this guy is a
spoiled boy I know is even castling long
yeah how do how do I play this maybe
still here
now you cannot go f6 as e-cigs hang so
at least some activity
yeah there is it's not full compensation
but it's it's I can I can somehow hang
on i'm going back here can still not end
with the airport maybe I get in c4d 5
those kind of moves c4 c5 maybe
okay maybe I can let's play this end
game if we get all the looks of the
board I'm not losing this I don't think
so look T for maybe as a move that's
actually good let's hope is not finding
it prob deform ok so we trade our loops
yeah well that that's that's that that i
will not do some pretty sure let's see
f6 is the only way for him forward and
if i get all the way to deform this is
ok let's see take sticks take once and
King you form takes King takes this is
not even better for black but it might
be it might be enough to hold not
totally sure but um it might be enough
so he wants to bring the King over
somehow I mean f5 is an immediate draw
I actually offered me a draw yeah so I'm
going to it is really just the wrong
yeah he accepted her it's um he can do
nothing it's just the blockade it's
actually instructive a little bit if we
go back him he could he can do that
maybe that's an idea I know that he's
not directly threatening the pawn
because d8 Hanks but he might have King
c7 and then it's hanging and I think
this is a better a better tribe I don't
really I don't have an active way to
play as something like that is not going
to go into work yeah it was a that was
the kind of yeah the black madam oh okay
so guys we are on for one hour I hope
you in enjoyed this this broadcast yeah
i'm playing viewers little but not after
one hour after one hour the show is over
yeah i hope you enjoyed it got some
funny games going I didn't score that
well but it wasn't terrible yeah so i
hope you liked it and i'll be online
next week i guess i hope you all back
also check the icc channel here for
other shows yeah there's other stuff
been to blitz the sim your master all
kinds of things thanks for watching guys
and I'm back next week bye